et maintenant
bon
ouais si jamel debbouze
jamel
je vous demande de vous arrêter
et c'est super gentil jamel qu'est ce
qui vous en payez alors ça va super bien
d'accord alors qu'il enchaînait j'ai lu
dans vsd tu vas me dire c'est la soirée
vsd mais j'ai lu dans vsd que la
dernière fois que c'était les enfants de
la télé arthur vous a pas trouvé assez
drôle vous a reproché de ne pas assez
faire le show d'avoir nique et son
émission et vous avez dit j'ai envie de
dire casse toi arthur alors je vais vous
dire ici vous êtes en famille si vous
voulez pas être drôle c'est pas grave
non
c'est difficile votre gmail de boules de
pâte drôle parce qu'il a été récemment
sacrée artiste plus drôle du monde sur
m6 voilà il ya sondages bien sondage
énergie ou jamel a été élu deuxième
artiste préféré des auditeurs derrière
madonna ça va derrière madonna
m comme l'année d'avant comme l'année
d'avant il était l'artiste le mieux payé
de france
c'est un livre des records à lui tous à
jamel debbouze
alors que j'aurai un vrai plaisir de
venir chez toi tu étais on est heureux
camara merci je suis content alors
record également dans le nombre de dvd
de 100% debbouze mis en vente
cinq cent mille exemplaires mis en vente
c'est la plus grosse mise en vente
encore c'est la plus grosse mise en
vente pour un humoriste one man show
500000 exemplaires alors djamel sérieux
c'est bon je te laisserais ya rien à
rajouter c'était super g et un slalom et
500000 la promo ça doit être l'enfer
souhaite une tuerie dont tu vas faire
que des télés des radios toute la
journée ou quoi mais là c'est vrai qu'on
est là là là là je dois avouer que
s'appelle marathon nérin mais c'est un
vrai qu'ils feront pas se voir je passe
voir dénommé mon ami arthur et plein de
gens à voir comme ça elle a remarqué il
ya deux dvd il ya un premier dvd avec le
spectacle que vous avez co écrit avec
kader aoun
moi non plus je ne connais pas non plus
que je m'entends du coup kader aoun qui
est également responsable la mise en
scène
et puis il ya un bonus sur le deuxième
dvd alors il ya le making-of alors on
voit comment vous comment vous approchez
vos spectacles vos doutes vos angoisses
c'est pas c'est un travail de longue
haleine c'est ça la rigolade
ouais le résultat est marrant mais ce
qui se passe avant il ya des jours c
mais c'est comme toi tu t'es un peu
obligé de se lever le matin de préparer
des interviews sur youtube je passe pour
un combat voilà sinon c'est toi qui es
obligé de faire le show mais c'est comme
tout une question travaille d'abord il
faut il faut bosser pour pouvoir marais
être à l'aise alors survenue six as a
donc les interrogations de djamel sur
son métier sur le spectacle il ya des
rencontres avec un certain nombre de
personnalités et puis à le petit pont
avec zidane 1 sur la pelouse du stade
non mais vous rigolez pas c'est vraiment
sérieux un tête à tête avec
le gall est là là il ya un tête à tête
avec gym des musées dame au stade de
france
et c'est pas du cac gagné alors lieux
saints bientôt mère 6 mai qui fait la
première partie de votre tournée et puis
à le spectacle après le spectacle enfin
bon voilà quoi donc il ya de quoi quand
même un bon c'est pas foutu de la halle
de l'hymne nazi surnom mais mais mais
mais vraiment pour parler plus
sérieusement moi je suis très fier de ce
spectacle pour plein de raisons parce
que parce que effectivement ça s'appelle
pas 100% debbouze pour rien avec kader
on sait on s'est vraiment approché le
maximum de la forme de spectacles qui
m'intéressait le plus à savoir le
stand-up ça peu à la manière d'aider des
anglo saxons richard pryor eddie murphy
des meilleurs unis bruce wayne lenny
bruce et j'adore j'adore 16,7 cette
forme de spectacle parce que ça reste
une conversation entre un président être
un cousin voisins donc qui qu'arrive sur
scène comme comme dans son salon et qui
te raconte ce qui lui est arrivé la
veille c'est c'est un vrai qui fait
parce que si jamais la même chose et
c'est super marrant que c'est plus dur
quand même arriver tout seul sans avoir
des sketches que les gens connaissent
juste en parlant comme ça devant une
salle et avoir le contact les faire
marrer moi j'ai vu le spectacle de fois
chaque fois les gens étaient pliés de
rire
j'adore ça vraiment ouais c'est sûr
notre activité permanente et insouciants
de la part j'allais dire c'est sincère
en temps c'est bizarre de dire ça mais
c'est vrai que c'est il ya un truc qui
passe entre le public avec le public à
ce moment là elle est avec les sketches
si je pouvais pas croire venir ça parce
que ce qui est enfermée dans un
personnage dans une situation aucune
chute ou argent alors que là c'est alors
la meilleure façon de vendre 500 milles
c'est de regarder ce qui est dans vous
allez regarder votre caméra vous jamel
et vous allez dire magnéto serge manitou
charge